i would strongly argue that nen is
probably the greatest power system ever
featured in
all of media it's unbelievably sturdy
versatile and at times painfully logical
however even then within this limitless
concept there are still going to be
people who fail so spectacularly that it
makes nen
look like utter garbage hello and
welcome to the new world review source
for everything anime and manga and today
we are unsealing the pits of shame
within the realm of hunt hunter to cast
some much needed sunlight onto the worst
nin users in the series
and in particular we are on a hunt to
discover the single worst nen user
although to do that we need to invoke
the assistance of glorious
science the first step of said science
being you subscribing to the new world
review in order to receive regular hot
hunt content uploaded straight into your
youtube feed
consider pressing that button the
equivalent of putting on a lab coat it
is for your benefit and it will make you
look much smarter than you already are
having used the s
word though we're going to quickly run
through our methodology here and if
you'd like to skip to the actual list
then you can do so by heading to this
time however i would greatly encourage
you to stay and for the less you know
attentive of viewers we will have a
slideshow in the bottom corner here
featuring some of the ladies of hunter
hunter so you just keep your eyes
focused down there whilst i speak to the
academics in the room so the basic idea
was to measure and quantify menus via
four categories
aura efficiency versatility and mastery
each of which was given a score out of
25 and they were then combined into a
total score out of 100
and obviously here today we are
featuring the 20 lowest of those scores
with the aura category the idea was to
measure in then use it by a sheer
quantity of aura because the more aura
one has the more they can invest into
menus it's kind of like money really the
more you have the more you can make of
it fair warning though there are not
going to be many high aura scores in
this particular video oh no
next up we have efficiency which aims to
determine how effectively an end user
implements aura think of it this way if
gone uses two units of aura to conjure
a watermelon and kilauea uses one unit
for it to do the exact same thing then
kilowatt is being more efficient and
gone is failing as per usual then we
have versatility which is all about
determining how useful an individual's
nan use can be in any given situation
basically are you a swiss army knife of
life like moral
or are you a one-hit wonder like komagi
and finally we have mastery which takes
into account experience and theoretical
knowledge people who have engaged in
formal known study will do quite well
here whilst those who developed their
abilities naturally may struggle or
someone who studied formally and just
sucks may struggle as well so there's
ever so many options but with that out
of the way let's get into this
disappointment fest starting with the
20th worst end user in hunter hunter
which will be theta dipping into the
manga realm immediately we find
ourselves with the very
unfortunate bodyguard of 4th prince
radnick and theta ends up being pretty
average in most areas due to the little
we know about her however she does have
a bit of time to shine in the mastery
category because she does have an
extremely solid theoretical knowledge of
nen although she does suffer with aura
because as of right now
theta is nothing special there or well
anywhere else all in all theta is kind
of
standard not a terrible user by any
means just very unlucky to catch the end
of this list onwards to number 19 though
we stumble across
one pockle poor poor yet delicious
pockle another fairly average contender
although i will say that he does earn
some extra points in versatility due to
his ranged arrow attacks which he
clearly possesses multiple forms of for
different situational uses which is nice
i like that the problem is the situation
in which we saw him use these arrows
well they didn't really work out too
well for buckle there and as for aura
well this is going to be a running theme
here but it's nothing impressive
although i will say that an aura score
of 10 is actually pretty high for this
list so
good on pockel for that at the very
least much lower aura comes to us in the
form of
one squalor who finds himself in 18th
place and unfortunately he's quite
mediocre in most of these areas
although he does have some strength and
versatility primarily due to his
manipulation affinity manipulation is
always fun because you can make people
animals or things do essentially
anything you want although in squalor's
case he has chosen to use dogs
exclusively so it's not the most
effective use of targets furthermore he
clearly doesn't have the raw aura to
make this manipulation efficient either
as he had to set a restriction of taking
complete care of the dogs at all times
in exchange for this ability however he
is living every dog lover's dream or i
suppose he was living it
past tense is important but for one of
the most interesting contenders on this
list i now present to you
komagi in 17th place she is a very
special nen user and the only candidate
in this entire video who achieved a
perfect score in any area which is
efficiency
komagi has incredibly low aura output no
versatility outside of the game of gungi
and in terms of mastery all she has is
raw natural instinct which is indeed
something but not quite enough
however komenki uses what little she has
so damn efficiently even subconsciously
setting a restriction of death in the
case that she loses a gunky match and
you can even legitimately argue that
komagi has one of the single best
individual uses of nen in the entire
series and had events played out a bit
differently during the chimeran talk i
honestly don't think that meruem ever
would have defeated her that is just how
incredible komiki's ninus was but under
this criteria
she does fall unfortunately short for
another unfortunate candidate in 16th
place we have zushi and i have to say
it's not
really fair that he's on this list
because he's a child and only just
learning men not only that buzushi is
also a very very talented child and 10
years from now he could find himself on
the list of best end users but under
these conditions he just doesn't compare
very well
understandably so as his current aura
quantity is very modest and he lands
himself in a very middling position for
both versatility and efficiency although
he does score slightly above average in
mastery due to being taught a phenomenal
amount of theory by wing and all i can
say is i look forward to a future where
we do get to see zushi's growth however
that day
is certainly not today stopping off at
the lovely greed island now we have
abengane in 15th place and he's a tricky
one because abengani does possess very
solid mastery in particular he is quite
wildly perceptive when it comes to nine
and has a great theoretical
understanding of the art form where he
really falters though
is pure versatility which is to be
expected since he isn't a nexus abangani
possesses one of the most
niche possible abilities in the entire
world only truly able to use his skill
to act against nan curses which are
already
extremely rare although at the very
least he is able to exercise curses
placed on himself so that does
add some versatility points yeah not a
lot though
although someone who does do quite well
in versatility can be found further
down this shame hull would shout mono in
14th place he's natural admit a bit his
primary ability makes use of
manipulation which will almost always
result in an above average score for
versatility but shachmono's ability 11
black children comes with some big
big big problems one being that they
cost an absolutely stunning amount of
aura to emit in the first place which
means that once constructed they can
only obey the simplest of commands and
furthermore they can only actually exist
within a few meters of shachimono
himself and if you compare this to
something like razer's 14 devils you
will realize pretty quickly that shamono
is a budget inferior version
being painfully inefficient and
demonstrating that he simply does not
have the raw aura to make an ability
like this
actually work still probably better than
number 13 who is
ponzu and by now you're probably
noticing a bit of a trend with this list
in that many of the users we've explored
are rather unfortunately dead and that's
not really a coincidence in fact it very
much speaks to the quality of nen users
that they were in life because nen is a
very brutal practice
that will rather swiftly weed out the
weaker wielders and ponzu while she
never really stood a chance
also of note is that she is one of the
only manipulators to have received a
very middling score for versatility
because she chose to manipulate
bees and if there is something less
versatile than dog manipulation
i would definitely say the bees are
certainly up there meanwhile ranking in
12th position we find an owl or more
accurately a man named al
a very unremarkable man in almost every
sense however what keeps him out of the
top 10
is his beautifully simplistic nan
ability the fun fun cloth which can be
used to shrink whoever or whatever ends
up inside of it kind of like a pocket
dimension in fact it's a highly inferior
version of nov's hide and seek but even
then
that's still pretty amazing and it's
very clear why crollo decided to steal
this power sadly that was all al had
going for him but it's certainly better
than the rest of the shadow beast
definitely better than the rest for an
actual beast we are back to chimera and
town to focus on hina in 11th place so
like carbon ghana hina isn't a nexus and
as a result she will receive an equally
as low scored versatility assuming that
she can remove nen curses on herself
that is
if not it should be even lower but the
more concerning difference between hina
and abengana
is mastery abengana has a wealth of
experience in theoretical knowledge
whereas hina has just sort of stumbled
into nen like most of the ants in fact
when it comes to the ants in general
it's very much like giving nuclear
weapons to a toddler they become
very very powerful but with highly
limited knowledge of what they're
actually doing having said that though
i'm not even sure if that applies to our
number 10 finisher blosster one of the
very few chimera ants to achieve
something of a happy ending in the
series so
good on him although there's a very
simple way to think about blosster and
his menus which is just an inferior
version of franklin bordeaux from the
phantom troop loster is franklin just
with less aura less efficiency
far less mastery and limited versatility
because he really only does
that one thing it's very uninspired to
say the least
and utterly pathetic to say the most but
in ninth place now we have another
intriguing contender known only as the
meteor city elder and if you're an anime
only watcher this man was basically
responsible for defending the junkyard
city which he did through his ability
the sun
and the moon which was effectively used
to turn residents of meteor city into
kamikaze bombers which i suppose worked
well enough but it did show a lack of
almost everything it was efficient sort
of and i will say that the ability was
seen as useful enough to be taken by
crawler to use in a very
specific scenario though and in
crawler's defense he did put it to much
better use but this is a clear case of
nen spawning from raw desire there is no
mastery at play here it's just the old i
have a mission and here is my very crude
way of achieving said mission however
moving on to number eight we have
sarasota and i don't want to spend too
much time on him because he is a failure
for obvious and very well documented
reasons i do want to give him a tiny bit
of versatility related credit though
because he does transmute aura to
replace his lost arms and having arms is
a pretty useful thing
can confirm although all it really does
is even out the playing field against
people who didn't lose their arms when
learning none so
yeah that sounded so you're still
nowhere near the best in fact you're
almost the worst according to this list
but now we have number seven where we
find a protagonist by the name of laorio
and i really didn't want to shame leoria
by putting him on this list because i
love the character but he's given me
very very little option as someone who
actively put off learning then he is
still
very behind in the series and he always
will be his mastery and aura quantities
are indisputably low and at best he
receives middling scores for efficiency
and versatility and it's a great shame
because once again i do really like the
character but i suppose that's what
happens when your author well
kind of abandons you or poorly oreo
still at least seventh is better than
six
in this case anyway not in all cases in
the best end users list six was better
than seventh but regardless in sixth
place here on this shame list we have
revelt
another heavens arena reject who uses
nen in the most basic of ways to
overcome a fundamental problem caused by
an
unfortunate initiation however west
harrison achieved some nice versatility
rebel lands in a more awkward zone
basically only using nan
as you would a mushroom in mario kart
with that said i would still consider
him slightly better than our number five
finishes plural which are
all of the shadow beasts minus al this
was quite fascinating because i did rank
the shadow beast individually but with
the exception of al they all
ended up with the exact same stats
because they are all equally awful in
every area i really don't think there's
a single nen user who would ever have
cause to be concerned about this group
they mostly exist to intimidate and deal
with non-end users but their abilities
are just so
niche and poorly thought out that i
decided just to combine them into one
glob of mediocrity so here they are for
your viewing displeasure now as for
number four we have a candidate who i
almost
expected to win being chito and that's
because he is quite possibly
the single most pathetic nin user in the
series paying no real attention to how
to manifest desire to achieve
an actual outcome because every ability
he produces either on his own or with
the help of shayapot's cocoon is
completely counted to his strengths and
personality and if anything becomes a
serious hindrance rather than a benefit
and as a result chito spends the
majority of the series being
consistently clowned right up until his
unceremonious exit however what i cannot
deny is that chitu has a fantastic
horoscope he is blessed with aura in
ways that most characters could only
dream of
it's just heavily misused and abused but
the aura factor alone will save him from
being crowned as the worst nen user here
today
now as for someone who topped chitu our
bronze medal will be awarded to guido
our third heavens arena failure who uses
aura in by far the most questionable way
amongst the trio not really paying any
heed to assisting his debilitation and
instead just having fun
playing with spinning tops yay which is
all at once not versatile not efficient
a very poor demonstration of aura
quantity and of course
mastery is not a word that will ever
ever apply to guido and you can
definitely say the same for our second
place finisher zeho
and who is zeho you ask well that's a
good question
zejo is one of the greed island players
and i should take this opportunity to
say that i did not rank most of these
players
because there's just not enough
information about them however zeho here
is a very special brand of failure who
we did get quite a bit of insight on and
it
was not good zaho is a super simple
enhancer who struggles with even the
basic principles of nen for example he
had great difficulty producing even the
simplest of applications of ren
and he was defeated by bopabau another
character who you could essentially
consider a fodder existence
so when you were worse than a throwaway
antagonist and that doesn't speak very
well to you does it
zero although to be fair he was
definitely not the worst nin user i
discovered before we get to that though
let's answer a curious question being
where
are gone and killer so very
interestingly these two did not rank on
the best net users list and they're also
not on this list so where did they end
up while out of 119 characters gone fell
into 35th place whilst kilauea landed
slightly higher
in 33rd place which unfortunately means
that they did not get to be featured in
either top 20 list but this does make
all the sense in the world to me because
throughout hunter hunter gone and
kilauea are consistently in over their
heads they are too talented but very
young students thrust into a world of
masters and when you think about it
neither one of them
ever really defeated a particularly
skilled opponent outside of the pito
situation which was an aberration
other than that gone and kilauea are
famous for taking on low-skilled men
users like the heavens arena trash or
basic chimera ants
and as soon as they come up against
those with a decent level of nen skill
they crumble almost immediately
be that hisoka the phantom troop the
royal guard or even
knuckle and shoot god and killer just
cannot stand up to the more experienced
end users of this world so much like
zushi yes they are
really talented young lads but just far
too young and inexperienced
to really compete against even 20 of the
series best nine users but to finally
discover our number one worst nine user
in the series it is none other than
neonastra because within her we have a
sort of komagi style situation happening
just without the guard-like efficiency
and with significantly less natural
mastery i would almost
say no natural mastery because i have no
idea how neon generated the lovely ghost
writer ability
but outside of this very very specific
application
she seems to have limited to arguably no
knowledge of men
and while her hatsu is indeed very
unique it does come with some painful
restrictions one of which being that
neon can't even predict her in future
and once again this may very well be one
of the single greatest nun abilities in
the series but in terms of nen usage
neon falls right to the bottom of the
shame barrel and shall be ordained as
the worst nen user
in all of hunter hunter and if you'd
like to see more then fun then please do
check out this video of the top 20 best
end users in the series i promise there
will be much
less disappointment in that video so i
look forward to seeing you there